hey youtubers is Charlie what is
happening there's new Doctor Who footage
so this is gonna be a breakdown of that
lots of classic Daleks that we haven't
seen in a while there is like a
hierarchy so I'll explain what all the
different Daleks look like and we get a
good shot of Skaro which is really cool
whole lot of Maisie Williams - what I'm
gonna do is I'm just gonna take this
scene by scene like some of these scenes
are stitched together but they're broken
up across the trailer and have you never
seen Doctor Who before I did do like a
series 9 beginner's guide I'll put a
link to that in the description so you
guys are caught up it doesn't start till
September 19th and it's all on Netflix
so this is line on the trailer where the
Daleks say what is happening and the
doctor just says business as usual
that's what a lot of these early shots
imply just him and the TARDIS business
as usual him and Clara out having
adventures that's one of the core ideas
of series 9 is that it's not so much
about them getting used to each other
it's about them being okay with each
other like Clara being okay with the new
doctor and then just going out and
having fun like they should be nevermind
the search for Gallifrey and the fact
that Missy is still alive and she's
tailing them so here's a glorious shot
of this Maisie Williams episode she's in
a two-part episode it'll be a full two
hours supposedly part one is called the
girl who died part two is called the
woman who lived so that might be who
Maisie Williams character is I know
everyone wants her to be Susan or Jenny
like the doctor's daughter
Steven Moffat did one of those things
where he's like she's not that person
you think she is or I might be lying if
you've been a longtime fan of who you
know all about the Moffat lies meme so
you can take that take that as you will
like he could possibly be like she could
possibly be Susan or Jenny but I still
kind of think that she's a new character
the episode though it looks like it
takes place entirely in period so if
we're gonna be on earth in this episode
or these two episodes then it'll be like
robots of Sherwood with fantasy stuff in
a real environment because there's this
Thundercat standing next to her in this
alternate shot and it looks like he can
breathe fire these are some of the new
monsters that they created for series 9
most of the monsters are new this year
but there are a few familiar ones the
cool thing about this Maisie Williams
episode is that it also has a character
named Merlin Odin and screwin Roger who
did the face of boat during earth think
red lock everybody wave to John
Barrowman over on arrow season 4 you
know look it's a dragon what a
coincidence I wonder how Emilia Clarke
feel
about this I'm gonna call it Nymeria
until we get the actual name in the
episode no idea what this hallway is
this could imply a lot of different
things
hi ball hands look amazingly terrifying
mysteriously similar to the Sibylline
sisterhood from the fires of Pompeii so
this actually might be that fires of
Pompeii episode in the in the original
conception of the series like during
series 4 it was intended to explain why
the doctor can change history sometimes
and sometimes he can't but the way
Moffat explained it in series 9 is that
they're gonna revisit that so that they
can explain why the 12th doctor's face
looks like this characters face if you
remember this is actually one of the
characters that Karen Gillan played
before she was recast as Amy Pond this
actually looks like jovi and wade he's
actually coming back if you remember he
was in last season's episode flatline
the one where everybody got sucked into
two dimensions I'm assuming that he's
reprising the same character so I'm
really enjoying the oh face here
like oh god not again
sigh cons of course they're actually
they're gonna play a big role this
series they're getting a two-parter
themselves to Oz that is coming back in
this episode they didn't explain how
because supposedly Missy killed her
during series 8 but it's gonna be like a
unit episode so we'll see Kate Stewart
and like a long time Doctor Who monster
actor is coming back his name's Aiden
cook but he starred in the rings of
akhaten hide nightmare and silver the
day of the doctor and time of the doctor
Clara smirking with a bazooka and her
motorbike which we haven't seen in a
little while this might be the same
motorbike from the 50th anniversary
she's dressed all in black so either
she's on some sort of hardcore mission
or something weird is going on with her
there have been seasons of Doctor Who
where companions weird like almost the
same outfit for the entire series and
then there been times when they change
outfits all the time because Clara was a
schoolteacher and she was going on dates
with Danny pink she got a bunch of
different costume changes a lot of you
guys were asking me on Twitter if this
was Gallifrey no this is scar Oh from
before the Dalek war before the planet
was ravaged this shot is actually you
know Maj to a classic first Doctor
episode called the Daleks they went to
Skaro and you get this far away shot of
a Dalek city that looks just like this
this looks like it's just further inside
that episode inside the Skaro episode
this looks like one of the new monsters
we don't really know much about it but
this reminds me of Tony Stark and at
first
iron man movie come at me bro Clara
Missy and the doctor having some fun
this looks like a follow up on one of
those eyeball hands so I'm guessing that
that shows up in a Missy episode it just
feels right that miss you should get all
the really creepy stuff so here we see a
red Dalek and a couple blue Daleks the
blue ones are kind of like intermediate
Daleks that served this red one this
kind of reminds me of the supreme Dalek
the last time we saw him was during the
Davros episodes in the Medusa cascade so
this this might be like a completely
different Dalek it just visually it
looks like that Dalek here's another new
monster really don't know anything about
him
just looks very sophisticated and
terrifying this is another new monster a
little more humanoid I still think of
like most villains as monsters
especially if they're wearing a lot of
prosthetics this is kind of a funny way
to end the trailer just because the
doctor strict no hugging policy so they
probably included this just to show that
he's softening up just a little bit and
so that's it so just reminder it's
coming out the 19th of September that's
a Saturday it's a Saturday show if you
haven't watched it before I'll be doing
videos each week for it I'll try and do
q and A's if I can but it's gonna bump
up with Walking Dead and my Game of
Thrones stuff on Sunday so it's all
figured out but I will do a giveaway
actually I'll go ahead and start a new
round of the giveaway now all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video I'll just
let it run until we get like another
Doctor Who trailer which should come in
about two weeks now that we're getting
really really close let me know what do
you guys think about all these new
Doctor Who monsters really the biggest
things in my mind are the big saigon
episode finding out what's going on with
Osgood what's going on with Missy and
what her plan for the doctor is the
mystery of Maisie Williams and if she's
ever gonna come back and visiting Skaro
again what is happening so in case you
guys haven't seen it you can click here
for my Doctor Who beginner's guide it's
just a couple episodes that I recommend
based on core concepts and you can click
here to learn all about the new stuff
that's happening with the flash and
arrow they just dropped a couple bombs
yesterday thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you